the omicron variant is spreading around
the world and is on track to become the
dominant strain of the coronavirus here
in the u.s cases and hospitalizations
are surging prompting a new wave of
canceled events the rapid emergent
emergence of this strain also has many
questioning whether they should rethink
their holiday travel plans dr eric
topple founder and director of scripps
research translational institute joins
us now for analysis dr tobo thank you so
much for being here i want to jump right
in because as you know it feels really
eerily similar to march of 2020 and i
just want to run through some numbers we
got from new york today reporting over
20 000 new coveted cases which is the
highest daily total of the pandemic so
far hospitalizations also rose from 74
to 3
839 and among the triple jabs among us
we're really wondering can we do
anything to avoid getting sick is it
inevitable that we're all going to get
this
well good to be with you madison
it is not inevitable we don't have to
have a mea culpa to the omicron virus we
know all the things that were we knew
that back in early 2020 and we know it
uh here as we move on to 2022.
uh it's a respiratory virus and mask and
distancing and ventilation and air
filtration all these things are great
and the better the mass the better
protection there but also uh we have
vaccines we have uh boosters which are
essential
and we also have and forthcoming a pill
that's going to be highly effective
nearly 90 reduction of hospitalizations
and deaths so you know
there's no reason to despair we just
have to really work to ante up to the
omicron virus so if you've done
everything right if you're boosted and
you're you know fully inoculated should
you still plan to go home for the
holidays if you have those trips planned
or should people rethink their holidays
well that's an individual choice but i
mean i think
the best thing of course would be to
stay put because the risk would be
almost zero if you really weren't out
there
traveling and
mingling with other people however
obviously that's not practical and we
want to move on in our lives as much as
we can so if there's a risk but i
already reviewed the mitigating factors
of that risk the one thing that is
disappointing madison is the rapid test
we don't have them freely available
widely available throughout the country
if we had that then we could tell who's
infectious uh and when and
provide that really precise guidance
that would make a huge difference well i
i want to ask you
i want to ask you about those rapid
tests because one thing that's concerned
me is that people are taking at-home
rapids and potentially testing positive
and that's not getting counted as part
of our national total of cases do you
feel like that's accurate do we not have
a clear picture of how bad this is
because of at-home testing
well we haven't had a clear picture uh
since day one in the u.s
uh the pcrs have always been uh
constrained and a problematic i'm not
worried about people doing rapid tests
on their own that's better than nothing
and our test our data tracking in this
country has been pathetic so no i think
the more important thing is for the the
person who's involved to have the
information and that's by the way
madison that's one of the reasons why
the fda has done such a a poor job of
getting these tests approved in this
country there's more than 60 that have
been approved by the european uh medical
agency
right and on top of that speaking of
things that the fda has been slow to
approve we also have the uh treatments
right and we have uh the the
treatments that have not gotten approved
yet from the fda but are in existence
just waiting to to get doled out what do
you make of the delay there
well the pax levate
the pill which has the high potency i
mentioned
that should be imminent that the fda
should approve it it's already gotten uh
through uh european authorities uh but
the real issue there is that it's potent
it's safe but we're not going to have
enough of these pill blister packs for
five days we've got to go into high gear
production so here i don't think the
bottleneck is going to be regulatory
we'll have that in a matter of days it's
just going to be the supply
so when you look kind of taking a step
back here and when you look at how the
u.s has handled this pandemic as a whole
what grade would you give our federal
health agencies in terms of their
response to this and why
well year one was it was an uh absolute
f
of in every respect
um and that's why we peaked in january
of this past year because of that
blatant failure here in this second year
it's been better in terms of a very
aggressive vaccine campaign the problem
is the virus has gotten tougher and
tougher and we've had such a poor uptake
of vaccines we still have tens of
millions of people who haven't had a
vaccine we have tens of millions of
people who need to get boosted haven't
shown up for that and we have problems
with distribution of boosters our
testing has never gotten better we've
never distributed kn 95 mass to every
american or rapid test for free to every
american that's the kind of stuff we
should be doing that's what other
countries are doing to mount a
successful aggressive counter to the
virus so in your view the testing is the
key thing that we could change right now
to mitigate the spread of omicron
it sure would
i would add though better masking would
be another plus so those two together
it's never vaccines only it's not just a
vaccine-centric strategy you got to use
all the tools that we have and we're not
using them
do you think that the idea that the
boosters are going to save us then in
that case is that an unfounded idea
no they're going to help but there's no
save there's no they're not perfect
against omicron by any means but they
provide
about a doubling of protection from not
getting boosted and we're waiting too
long to give the boosters we know that
by four months there's a lot of waning
and we still in this country have a
six-month policy that doesn't go along
with the data if we're going to say
we're going by the science then go by
the science and it's not being done here
so so you think we should right now it's
like us i think six months between
boosters do you think it should be
closer to three
well that's what other countries are
using because it takes two weeks for
that booster to take its full effect
you know three or four months i'd go
with four that's very reasonable but not
six that means we're leaving so many
people out there two months dangling
when they're vulnerable well i want to
also talk to you about an idea that i've
heard from a lot of friends when i sound
a little bit freaked out about omicron
they say well if you get it you're not
going to be that sick because you're
triple vaxxed is that accurate
well it is milder for sure yeah but it's
because of the vaccines because of the
immune wall that you
and others have built
but it's not predictable fully that is
we're not ready to have chickenpox
parties with omicron okay because it has
it can cause long covid it can be a very
significant illness
so if you can avoid it that's what you
want to do that's why you want to get a
booster that's why you want to use mass
and do everything we can to not get an
infection because you can't predict most
times it will likely be mild in a case
where you've had triple vaccination but
you can't you know say a hundred percent
is that this virus if anything has
taught us it's unpredictable we never
would have predicted the mutations of
omicron
everybody thought they would evolve to
some kind of delta lineage and look what
we have so
the way this is behaving we're three
weeks into it we don't know enough about
how how it's gonna
have sequelae downstream in time
so looking three weeks ahead what is the
impact of omicron going to be on our
health care systems what are you most
afraid of our country's public health
looking like in the weeks ahead
well we're going to get
probably at least a million cases a day
at some point
we're shooting up really fast and that's
just the beginning of the omicron surge
on top of a delta surge that we didn't
get control so let's say it is as i
believe it will be uh considerably
milder overall but when you have such a
big denominator of a million cases even
if it's ten percent as as uh of the
hospitalizations as delta that's still a
big taxing of our medical resources and
hospitals and and uh medical staff the
workforce
and a lot of sick people some of whom
won't even make it so that's the problem
is a big denominator even though there's
a smaller fraction of people who get
very severe disease of cova
and how worry are you about lawn covert
as well for the triple vaccinated
individuals who might come into contact
with omicron
well the vaccines will help we have some
good evidence that there's a reduction
of severity and the frequency of long
covert but i am worried about the
interaction between this virus which
evades our immune system
and long covalent which is at least in
part uh immune mediated so
if someone's not vaccinated and gets the
omicron there seems to be a higher risk
we'll only know over time that's what
the long coveted story is all about
with vaccination we we don't know that
either but there's a hope that it'll
blunt the potential
all right dr tobol i want to ask you
just a couple rapid fire questions that
we got in from our audience about how to
make our personal life decisions if you
don't mind just being our advisor here
for a moment while we have you really
quickly uh if you're triple vaxxed and
you test positive how long do you have
to quarantine
well that's a good question right now
you know people are advocating 10 days
but
most likely if you're vaccinated you're
going to have rapid clearance that's
simply what we saw with delta we got to
nail down those studies but in the
interim if you have
two or three days of rapid tests that
are negative that's probably a good sign
you've cleared the virus you're not
infectious
but you know we've got it we've got to
nail that down and that's just out there
dangling right now of course well if
you're just exposed but you don't
necessarily test positive yet should you
immediately jump into quarantining stay
home from school and work
that would be advised get some rapid
tests
and if you're not infectious after a few
days not having symptoms that would be a
good sign we're going to learn more
about that in the days ahead
restaurants yes or no
outside okay
inside i wouldn't go there
right now what about a dining experience
with your family over the holidays a
small house gathering
i have no problem with gatherings if
everybody is triple vaccinated uh and
ideally i have had rapid tests before
coming together for a couple few days
including the day of the gathering that
would be good having good ventilation
whether that's windows open hepa filters
co2 monitors you know pulling out of
those stops yeah but
you know if you just have a reckless
without the vaccines without all the
tools we know there could be a an issue
that evolves
so your your final message to folks who
are worried dr topple uh
it's not inevitable in your view that
we're going to get sick with this if
we're triple vaxxed there is there is
hope
no not at all i mean we don't want to
just surrender to this
it's premature to even think about that
there's too much unpredictable we have
too many tools and uh we we can avoid
this virus and prevail over it if we get
serious unfortunately that hasn't been
the case and we were warned uh you know
a few weeks ago and we still haven't
geared up
all right well hopefully uh everyone
hears what you're saying and goes and
gets tested as soon as possible dr tobe
will really appreciate you joining us
and thank you for all the insights
you've given us throughout the pandemic
i'm obviously a huge fan of your twitter
feed so thank you so much that was dr
eric topple founder and director of the
scripps research translational institute
thanks again